- [Instructor] Let's
see if we can figure out
what two divided by 0.1 or one tenth is.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Alright, now let's work
through it together
and there's a couple of ways
that we can approach it.
One way is to think about
everything in terms of tenths.
So two wholes is how many tenths?
Well a whole is equal to 10 tenths,
so two wholes is equal to 20 tenths.
So I could rewrite the two as 20 tenths.
And so that's gonna be
20 tenths divided by,
instead of writing it this way,
instead of just writing it as 0.1,
we know this is the
same thing as one tenth.
So divided by one tenth.
And so if I have 20 of something
and if I divide it into groups
of one of that something,
how many groups am I going to have?
Well I'm going to have
20 equal groups of one.
So 20 tenths divided by
one tenth is equal to 20.
Another way that you could
approach that is you could
rewrite the 0.1, the one
tenth, as a fraction.
We could rewrite this as two divided by.
Divided by.
Instead of writing one tenth like this,
I could write it as a fraction.
Divided by one tenth.
Well, we know that dividing
by a tenth is the same thing
as multiplying by 10.
So this is going to be equal to two times.
Two times 10.
And that gets us to the same
place that we had before.
What is two times 10?
Well that is going to be equal to 20.
And that's good that we
got to the same answer.
Otherwise, these would
not be equivalent methods.
Let's do another example.
So let's say we wanted to
figure out what six divided
by one tenth is.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Alright.
Well, you could do the same idea.
Six wholes is equal to how many tenths?
It's equal to 60 tenths.
So I'll rewrite this as 60
tenths divided by one tenth
is equal to how many is equal to what?
Well if I have 60 of something
and if I divide it into groups
of one of that something,
I'm gonna have 60 equal groups of one.
So this is going to be equal to 60.
So you might see a pattern.
When we divided by a tenth,
we ended up multiplying by 10.
When we divide by a tenth,
we are multiplying by 10.
And you could do the same
thing as we saw up here.
You could say six divided by
one tenth is the same thing
as six divided by one
tenth written as a fraction
which is going to be equal to six times.
You can say six times 10
or six times 10 over one.
Either way.
Six times 10 over one or
which is the same thing as 10
which is once again
going to be equal to 60.
So I think you see the general pattern.
Divide by a tenth same
thing as multiplying by 10.
Now what about if we
dealt with hundredths?
So let's say we wanna figure
out what seven divided
by a hundredth is?
What would this be?
Pause the video and try to figure it out.
Alright, well we can do the same drill.
So seven wholes.
One whole is equal to a hundred hundredths
so seven wholes is
equal to 700 hundredths.
So this is equal to.
I'll write it like this.
700 hundredths divided by.
Divided by one hundredth.
One hundredth.
If I have 700 of something and
if I'm dividing it into equal
groups of one of that something,
I'm gonna have 700 equal groups.
So this is going to be equal to 700.
So you divide by a hundredth
is the same thing as multiplying by a 100.
Now you could also rewrite
this as a fraction if you like
so that some of the principles
we saw up here still apply.
So we could rewrite this as
seven divided by one hundredth.
And so this is going to be
the same thing as seven times
100 over one.
Or seven times 100.
Seven times 100 which once
again, will get you to 700.
So I think you see a pattern.
Divide by a tenth, same
thing as multiplying by 10.
Divide by a hundredth, same
thing as multiplying by a 100.